these divers are searching this Lake
after several children drowned here
during a school trip
but hope is fading for those who are
missing police say 25 children were on
board a boat when it capsized on the
Waters of the Tanda Dam
only a few have been rescued
the tragedy is being blamed on the
vessel being old and overcrowded
and in a remote area in Balochistan
Province another fatal accident
passengers are traveling overnight from
quetta to the port city of Karachi when
their bus fell from a bridge and caught
fire police say the driver could have
been driving too fast and may have
fallen asleep at the wheel
now the rescue operation is completed 40
people died their bodies were taken to a
Civil Hospital in Karachi samples will
be collected from them and will move
them to a mortuary for identification
Pakistan has a poor road safety record
more than 27 000 people were killed in
Road accidents in 2018. Road Safety
experts say the high toll is due to many
vehicles being crowded and few people
wearing seat belts
Barbara and gopa Al Jazeera